Joanna's with us in Palm Springs
California hey Joanne how are you how
are you better than I deserve what's up
I just have a question about if it's
possible to inherit debt no my no okay
even if your name is on the purse my
name is not on any of the things like
the house sorry but all that if your
name is not on the dad it's not your
debt okay but my name he is my dad he
said he put my name on his bank account
would that give them ammunition to come
after me no they got that bank account
right no I didn't bother telling him but
that was pointless yeah anything
anything that he owns will be used to
pay off his debt when he passes away if
he doesn't own enough to pay off all of
his debt someone's not gonna get paid
you don't inherit debt but now if you're
if you're if you're including his
inheritance in something that yours then
you know that's going to be used up to
pay off debt before you get anything so
it's its assets minus liabilities what
you own minus what you owe is your net
worth and the net worth the net of the
debt is the only estate that he has it's
the only heritance that he has and so if
he has $100,000 in credit card debt and
$10,000 in a bank account and you know
he's got our v loans and a bunch of
other stuff you know there's not going
to be an inheritance here but you're not
gonna be liable for the difference the
debt is not passed on be very careful
not to sign stuff with this guy he's
completely out of control I know he's
your dad but he's completely out of
control and don't you you know don't put
your name on stuff just stay back away
from this car wreck and watch it happen
it's because you're gonna get you're
gonna get sucked into it if you keep
signing stuff and you're gonna end up
with a problem so but technically
speaking if you did not sign for the
debt you're not liable for the debt